las vegas has a bright economic outlook
at least that's what business experts
are saying at today's preview las vegas
the event features economists and
business leaders giving a look at the
year ahead here in southern nevada
hector mejia live this afternoon at
allegiance stadium where the event is
underway right now hector good afternoon
good afternoon to you john that event
discussion still going on inside of
legion stadium put on by the vegas
chamber the theme this year is battle
reborn as the las vegas economy comes
back from the pandemic
at the vegas chambers preview las vegas
event governor steve sisilak said about
11 000 new jobs are coming in the next
few years in manufacturing ev companies
and distribution facilities some new
things coming into the state coming into
southern nevada despite the omicron wave
the governor projects southern nevada's
economic future will be a bright one i
don't plan on having to take any steps
backwards we're moving forward in the
fight against covet and omicron right
now and we're going to continue to move
forward we're working on economic
diversification in bringing new and
emerging industries here to southern
nevada the las vegas economy will also
benefit from hosting major events like
the nfl draft and the super bowl prices
are not expected to drop anytime soon
though inflation is a big challenge for
our small businesses especially as the
price of goods increases and then
another thing that our small businesses
are having trouble with is the talent
pool these are all challenges that we at
the vegas chamber are working to help
them overcome
the vegas chamber added it was a pretty
big deal for them to host this event
inside a legion stadium the governor
noted it's a place that opened during
the darkest days of the pandemic
reporting live hector mejia live local
now